FRAN COSTIGAN: So I
don't even need this.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome.
I'm introducing
Chef Fran Costigan.
She's going to be doing a
little talk and a little demo
on her book "Vegan Chocolate."
So sit back, relax.
Don't spoil your lunch,
but have a piece of cake
if you already had lunch.
I hope you enjoy,
but here she is.
FRAN COSTIGAN:
Thank you very much.
I'm really so
excited to be here.
It's still winter in New
York, so that's one reason.
But it's a pleasure to come and
meet you, and I do desserts.
I changed my diet 22 years ago.
I was working as a
traditional pastry chef,
and I loved what I was doing.
I loved the work, but my
allergies and stomach-- I
couldn't take it anymore.
So I left.
I went into rock
and roll management.
That's a whole other story.
And I changed my diet
without thinking vegan.
You know I just said I read a
book called "Food and Healing"
by Anne-Marie Colbin.
Said I'll give up
dairy, but I actually
gave up all animal foods.
And I'm not the food police.
I never say to people
how can you eat that?
And this is the right
way for everyone.
Because it isn't.
We're a bio individual.
But for me-- and I do things
either black or white.
That's the way I tend to
be-- it was a miracle.
My allergies went away
except for yesterday
with all those purpley trees.
They seemed to be
making eyes run.
But no stomach
aches, great allergy.
I don't have to think about my
weight ever-- pretty much ever.
But I didn't want to do desserts
anymore, because I really
liked eating whole foods.
So I'm not a junk food vegan.
You know what I mean about that?
I eat plants.
I eat real food.
And then because it
was the very beginning,
I had just started
eating this way,
and I was so excited about
the way I felt. I did
get a little bit obnoxious,
a little bit food policie.
And my son, who was
about 12 at the time,
said you're not putting a
candle in a sweet potato
and telling me that's
my birthday cake.
Get back to making cakes.
So I went into the
marketplace 22 years ago.
It's not what it
is today at all.
I mean, everything tasted
dry or gummy to me.
And the recipe books-- and I had
gone through culinary school.
It didn't make any sense.
You used a cup of barley malt,
or a cup of sugar, or whatever.
Didn't make sense.
Nothing tasted good.
And the biggest insult was
someone handing me a cake,
not as pretty as this,
but it was brown.
And it didn't taste
like chocolate.
They were like, oh here.
You can have chocolate
cake, but it was carob.
So they're both brown.
That's about it.
I said, well, that's it.
Michael's not having
a baked sweet potato.
I don't want carob cakes.
There's nothing wrong with
carob, but it's not chocolate.
I went in, and I said I
went into the test kitchen.
I said if I can get a cake
that was as good as if not
better than a good version
of a conventional dessert,
then I'd be good.
And I say that because not every
conventional dessert you eat
is good, right?
But there were a lot of
bad vegan cakes there.
Today, I'm happy to say--
So this was my original--
a tweaked version
of my original cake,
the chocolate cake
to live for which one of
my testers, a non vegan,
went, oh my god.
This is a cake worth living for.
And it's stuck in a couple
of different incarnations.
Anybody here familiar with Rip
Esselstyn or the Engine 2 Diet?
Dr Esselstyn is Bill
Clinton's diet doctor
and reversed his heart disease.
So his son Rip
has Engine 2 Diet.
That was his wedding cake.
So I've been making it and,
today what I've learned-- I
didn't know any vegans
then, so I didn't really
know I was vegan.
I guess maybe I was macrobiotic.
But if you're allergic
to dairy, eggs,
don't want to use
white sugar, then
for me, this isn't about
what's not in the food.
It's that everybody
can be served.
So generally speaking,
I want to tell you
that Kathleen made the cakes,
and it's really gorgeous.
I asked her how'd you
get the glaze so perfect?
Because mine isn't.
Usually, I have to do
this Picasso effect, which
I'm going to do to show you.
The glaze was made
with almond milk.
And there's soy
milk in the cake.
Now, when I'm doing
something for a group
and I can't poll
people about allergies,
I just assume allergies
in today's world.
So I generally just
think there are
going to be people who avoid
soy and there are going
to be people who avoid nuts.
And I have found "So Delicious"
brand coconut milk beverage,
which is different from
canned coconut milk
but it's really just a plant
milk like almond milk, soy
milk, and so on.
Works great.
So you can make the same glaze
using coconut milk beverage.
In my book, I have
a recipe for making
a ganache with canned
coconut milk and so on.
So some of you probably
know things like this,
but I'm used to teaching.
I teach in New York City.
I teach everywhere
at this point.
I've seen vegan or dairy
free really explode.
And so I'm going to just say
things from the beginning
that you may already know.
Ganache is an emulsion,
typically of heavy cream
and chocolate in varying
percentages depending
on will it be a
glaze for a cake,
will it be the
center for a truffle?
I'm going to show you some.
I like to toast a really
delicious, crispy crostini.
You know, make a crostini?
I toast a baguette, spread
it with some olive oil,
and then smear it with
some thickened ganache,
and finish it with olive oil
and salt, and you have ganache.
It's chocolate milk
over ice cream.
To me, it's just
indispensable, and you
can keep it in your
refrigerator for at least a week
and in your freezer.
When you've made it ahead--
when I often make this ahead,
and it will look like this.
It will look like this,
which isn't so attractive,
but it will look like this.
Or this is better.
Like this.
And then this is the way it was
when I got here this morning.
And all I did was
make a water bath.
I don't use a double boiler.
I don't bother with that.
Just a saucepan with a
little bit of water in it.
You don't want
the bowl to touch,
and you don't want
steam, and you
don't want just a little
bit of steam or water
to touch chocolate.
When it does, anybody
have this happen?
I see heads nodding.
It seizes.
It gets gray.
It gets hard like pebbles.
And if it can be fixed-- maybe.
So you don't want to go there.
So just with some patience,
very slowly, you do this.
So it can be made ahead.
What you need is
a measured amount
of chocolate chopped very
finely in a heat proof bowl.
So the basic recipe
for enough glaze
to do a nine inch cake
with two coatings of glaze
is eight ounces of chocolate.
The right chocolate
to use is the one
that tastes good to you.
And I know from doing
chocolate tastings
with a lot of food bloggers,
and civilians, and so on we
all have individual taste buds.
So over here, these
two people-- it's
called the Food
Duo in New York--
said that chocolate
is so sour and tannic,
and other people
liked it and so on.
So it's up to you.
You have to do a
little homework.
If you want to work
with chocolate,
find the one that
tastes good to you.
But what isn't up to you if you
want the result to be positive,
successful, is that
you have to stay
within the percentage
of chocolate that's
listed in the recipe.
So I typically say 70
to 72% chocolate is my,
let's say, go-to to chocolate.
That works for most everything.
This glaze was made with
70% [? chow ?], right?
Yeah.
So it's a little bit-- it
might be a little bit softer.
So what happened here was I
don't think the sugar ever got
in here.
You bring whatever
plant milk you're
using, which would be almond
or coconut milk beverage
are my favorite.
Or if the recipe calls
for canned coconut milk--
to a boil.
It would be good to give it
a little stir, so I will.
So I knew that I would
have all the equipment
I needed here because
of the chefs were great.
But I travel teach a
lot, so I bring things
like my little baby measuring
cup and my little tiny whisk.
So you pour.
What's important is
the milk, the sugar,
and the pinch of salt
has come to a boil.
You pour it out.
You saw that I poured it over
the chocolate all at once.
If you just drizzle it
in, you're in trouble.
So you have to pour
it in all at once.
What I normally do, and I didn't
do, is not very scientific.
But I take a spoon, and
I put some of the milk.
I bring the milk to a boil.
A lot of other pastry
chefs, particularly vegan,
will tell you don't bring
the plant milk to a boil.
But I think it gives
a better result.
And then without picking
it up-- because I
have chocolate all over
me all the time anyway--
is just swirl it.
And now we're going to
pretend that this is
covered for about four minutes.
And people say, ugh.
Your recipes are so long.
That means they're hard.
They're not.
They are long, but I
say go in the kitchen,
turn on the lights, set the
rack in the right place,
turn on the oven thermometer.
A lot of detail.
The batter will be thin.
Don't worry about it.
Cover the chocolate.
So that's why they're long.
You give it a swirl.
I didn't trickle it in.
And I have found that by
letting the chocolate melt
into the hot liquid for about
four minutes really makes
a difference in the mouth feel.
You want something that's silky.
I would rather have it not
melt 100% than be too hot.
And I'll tell you what
happens if it's too hot.
If it doesn't melt, part of
my mise en place-- and that
just means getting
everything together
that you need-- if nuts need
to be roasted and cooled,
it's done.
Because you can't
always grind hot nuts.
It's great for nut butter
but not for nut flour,
and things like that.
Get them together.
So I have a saucepan.
You see how little
water is in here?
So it's always on the back
of the stove somewhere.
And if it didn't
melt altogether,
just put it over here.
Count to-- I usually
say sing happy birthday,
and you're done.
And now I'm going to
add a pinch of salt.
That's another thing I hear.
People seem to be
afraid to eat nowadays.
I heard that was
really bad for you.
I heard this was good for you.
This is bad.
That's good.
I don't know.
I think if we clean food,
that works for what we like,
if something is said to be a
super food or really fabulous
and you really don't like
it, your body is probably
saying it's not for you.
I haven't met anyone who doesn't
like chocolate yet though.
And I say chocolate is
a bean, and I eat beans,
but it's not a salad.
So get your healthy from
eating other things,
and then save room for this.
So I am stirring from
the center out, whisking.
Why from the center out?
I can only say that when
I was in culinary school,
my chef said serve ganache
from the center out.
Once it's smooth-- and
you can see that it is.
Can you see that it is?--
you really have to stop.
Two things can happen.
A few things can happen.
If the plant milk or any
liquid, because I have-- anybody
here like tahini?
I have an orange
juice tahini truffle
in this book that is so good.
It's just delicious.
So there is a case where
it's not a plant milk.
It's a different liquid.
But if the liquid is too
hot, what would have happened
is I'd be stirring,
and I have this
really lovely-- it's glossy.
It's lovely.
And all of sudden, just like
an oil slick on the top.
And it starts dancing around.
And what that is
was that the liquid
was so hot it was too
hot for the chocolate.
So the cocoa butter separated.
Now, cocoa butter isn't dairy.
It's the fat in chocolate.
It's the white fat.
And the other thing
that might happen
is if I just keep whisking
really vigorously.
Then it can get gritty.
So that's it.
I mean, I'm telling you that
this is a very easy recipe.
And it's very
variable, depending
on the kind of chocolate that
you use, the proportions.
You can make truffles with this.
You can do tons of stuff.
I added the salt, didn't I?
Because I feel it on my fingers.
Thank you.
I always need people in
the front to help me out
when I'm talking.
I don't always remember.
The next thing that I do
is I say to my students
when they leave, they're
like, oh I don't know.
We learned a lot of recipes
in vegan baking boot camp,
but the one thing I
remember is did you test?
Did you test?
And they say, well,
it tasted good.
Well, that's a taste test.
But a test is that
looks OK, but is it OK?
I don't know.
And I don't want to wait until
it's time to glaze the cake.
Company's coming.
Or I'm short on time, and I
have to run out for something.
I don't want to wait
until the last minute
to find out that this ganache
is too thick or too thin.
If it's too thick, I'll just
whisk in a little at a time,
stir in a little bit
more of the liquid.
If it's too thin, I'll melt
some chocolate and whisk it in.
So all you need to do--
I mean, sometimes I do it in
a little pinch cup, sometimes,
literally I'll take the whisk
and go like this on a plate.
Five minutes in a cold
refrigerator, and you
go like this.
What'll happen in
a few minutes--
and I'll show you-- is it
will look like it's set,
but you need to taste it.
Because is it creamy?
Is it too firm?
A lot depends on what you want.
Now, truthfully, I used a
little bit less milk in here
this time because I wanted
it to set up more quickly.
So we'll see what happens.
This isn't going
to set this way.
Anybody have any questions?
The only time I can
answer questions
is when I'm measuring.
It's impossible for me.
But other than that, any
questions about this?
Anybody here not like what's
called dark chocolate?
So I would say that the most
surprising fact that I learned
when I was researching "Vegan
Chocolate," which wasn't
my choice for a
title by the way,
but it just showed me how
the world's gone round.
I used to have to defend.
No, try it.
It's OK.
He Don't worry just
because it's vegan.
But now they wanted
to vegan in the title.
But also the tagline
says dairy free
because there are
people who walk by vegan
but really need
to be dairy free.
Almost everyone's lactose
intolerant, almost every adult
really if you do
a little research.
So what I learned was in
the United States up to 12%
milk or milk solids is
allowable in chocolate
that is non-milk chocolate,
that's labeled dark chocolate.
And you see it more in the less
expensive brands, not so much
in the premium brands.
It's definitely disclosed.
It will say cacao mass,
or unsweetened chocolate.
Those are interchangeable.
If you're using
organic sugar, it'll
say evaporated cane juice or
organic sugar or whatever.
Maybe some lecithin
and vanilla, and then
milk-- the words for milk.
And I was so curious about that
because I used to say-- not
exactly roll my eyes,
but when someone asked me
how do you know if
the chocolate's vegan,
I'm going to think, well,
if it's not milk chocolate,
I suppose it's
vegan unless you're
that really ethical vegan that
will only use vegan sugar.
Do you know what vegan sugar is?
So it's not filtered
through bone char.
And vegans used to like beet
sugar for that reason, years
before we had all these
choices, because that is never
filtered through bone char.
But because beets
are almost 100%
genetically modified
crop today, we
don't like beet sugar anymore.
So it's interesting.
I was doing a chocolate
dessert demo in Paris.
I got invited to
Paris Vegan Days.
And I was thinking, well, I'm
not going to turn Paris down.
That's for sure.
But that's an oxymoron
if I ever heard one.
And 10,000 people
came from all over.
Really.
There's a London veg fest now
and all this kind of stuff.
So I try to tell the same
story about the beets and GMO,
and the translator
pokes me and she
says not here, not in Europe.
We don't do GMO.
We don't buy your
foods and so on.
So there you go.
So the other ingredient
that belongs in here
is a little bit of oil.
It's optional.
It's about two
teaspoons per recipe.
But I feel that you
get the nicest feel,
the silkiest texture, and so on.
So we'll put that
aside, and I'm going
to use Kathleen's
glaze for this cake.
And I'm going to put gloves
on because I will get messy.
And then this is going to
get popped in the fridge.
What I like to do
is glaze it once,
let it set a little bit just
until it's not wet anymore,
and then glaze it a second time.
And that is the right
amount of chocolate to use.
I'm not very good
at cake decorating,
which is why I do what I'm
going to show you-- my Picasso
effect.
I tasted this.
It's delicious.
And it was as solid as
what I showed you earlier
when we got here.
So sometimes I just pour
it right out of here,
but that would be exceedingly
messy and I'm trying not to be.
So you could say that this is
perhaps a little bit thinner
than I might want it to be.
And you just go like this.
Sometimes, I do the cakes.
So you definitely want to
do it over parchment paper.
And then if you get the
paper cold, you know,
let it set up in
the fridge again,
you can reclaim this chocolate.
So I'm going to do
this, and then I'm
going to do the second glazing.
See why I don't I
wear a white chef coat
when I'm doing chocolate?
For obvious reasons.
Now, the recipe is for
a single layer cake.
But you just double the recipe
and you have a double layer
cake.
Well, I'm going to
put it right on here
because we were
doing that earlier.
So this can go in the
fridge if you wouldn't mind.
I'm going to get rid of these.
And now I want to
make-- let this set up.
So what you remember
is OK it's too firm.
I made it ahead.
I'm going to put it over a water
bath and let it get pourable.
But wait until it's
perhaps more like this.
And this will also be creamy
like a butter cream that
isn't a butter cream.
I never used to use the
word high speed blender
in any of my talks because
I didn't have the heart
to tell people that they
needed something so expensive.
And then I got one.
And it really is a game changer.
If you like being in the
kitchen-- and I mean,
I use my high speed
blender many times a day.
And what I have here is five
ounces of raw whole cashews
unsalted-- they're raw--
that have been soaked.
So you soak them for
four hours to overnight,
even if you're using
a high speed blender.
They can go overnight.
They could probably go two days,
but after that nothing happens,
especially if you
change the water.
I think you lose
some of the flavor.
If you want to make a
nut cream-- or this can
be a base for an ice
cream or many things--
we're going to serve
it you can taste it,
and you didn't remember to
soak the nuts, hot soak them.
Bring some water to a boil.
Put them in the boiling
water for just a few minutes,
drain them, and
they're ready to go.
Now, cashew cream has become
this like wow ingredient
in vegan non-dairy
desserts because it can
be used to do so many things.
So some of the savory chef say
but if you had soaked them,
they'll be a little sweet.
I don't care.
We're doing sweet.
So what I have in here, I'm
just going to get this started.
And then you get one.
What goes in here is-- I could
look at the recipe, couldn't I?
But I know it by heart.
Remember, that's fighting words.
That's dangerous.
Oh, I knew it by heart.
No, I really do know it.
So this one I do.
Cake, I'm going to show you.
I'm going to show
you how I measure.
So it's one cup of canned,
full fat coconut milk,
any brand that you like.
I never buy light
coconut milk in a can.
I spend a lot of money
on good ingredients
because you taste it.
What you put in, you're
going to get out of it.
If all you're going to taste
is the chocolate in the glaze,
you need to use a
chocolate that tastes good.
But I'm not paying for water.
So if I want light coconut
milk, I mix it with water.
So here this is very unusual
to have the coconut milk be
so solid all the way through.
Have any of you made the
coconut whipped cream
where you put the can of
coconut milk in the fridge
and then it's
supposed to separate?
Does yours always separate?
No, right?
Because they're
putting more and more
guar gum in the coconut milk.
So people like
coconut whipped cream,
which is when you take the
fat off here and mix it
in a stand mixer.
But I always chill the
can for at least 24 hours,
usually more, and I always have
an extra can because you just
never know.
There are some brands that
seem to be better than others.
That was a pinch of salt.
And now this and the ganache
are pretty much the only recipes
I have committed to memory.
My daughter-in-law wants me to--
Yeah, but if you have it there,
I wouldn't mind.
Six tablespoons of sugar.
So I am very bad at math.
My daughter's a statistician,
but I can't do math.
But I had to learn
some kitchen math,
so I know a quarter of a
cup is four tablespoons.
And a third of a cup is five
tablespoons and a teaspoon.
So when I'm baking,
when I'm doing desserts,
I really am precise.
I'm going to show you the
way that I measure for cakes.
Because the difference between
this is pretty good and great
can be a teaspoon,
or two teaspoons,
or the oven temperature
being wrong, and so on.
And it's a tablespoon of oil.
So my oil of choice--
in my earlier book,
I used canola oil.
Because remember,
I don't use butter.
And I don't use margarine,
because I consider that
an inferior product.
I mean, I would use butter
before I'd use margarine.
Now, I know a lot of people like
the Earth Balance margarines,
but I also don't use palm oil
because of the orangutans.
But I will tell you this.
Miyoko Schinner, who's a
friend and colleague of mine,
is coming out.
Her new book is
launching in June,
and it's called "Vegan Pantry."
And I stayed with her.
I was at San Bruno Google.
And I stayed with
Miyoko, who's nearby,
and I tasted her butter.
She also has vegan cheeses
that are unbelievable.
And you can make them.
If you have a blender,
you can make butter.
So pretty much that's it
except for the vanilla, right?
Right.
So before I turn this on,
because I can't talk over i,
what you're going
to have is this.
We made this earlier.
The full recipe
calls for grinding
the nuts, and the coconut
milk, and the pinch of salt,
and the vanilla, and so
on-- not the vanilla--
until this is very
warm, and then adding
a little bit of agar powder--
agar is vegetable jello.
Agar, agar-- the powder
until it actually boils,
and a little bit of guar gum.
And then it becomes
quite thick so
that this becomes
a pastry cream.
If you want to do a
fruit tart, but you
don't want to use a dairy cream,
creme anglaise or something
like that, it's really
gorgeous that way.
But as a sauce, you just can
leave the guar and the agar
out.
So this takes
pretty much no time
assuming I can get this-- This
a different kind of a Vitamix
from what I'm used to.
Yeah, I'll use-- I've learned
my lesson about putting
this in with the-- you know?
OK.
And it could be because
I didn't really measure,
which I never don't measure.
I just really relaxed today.
I think don't want to go home.
I like it here.
All right.
Like this.
I've learn two things about
using the high speed blenders.
And one is make sure
that the top is on here.
Must go this way.
Yeah, I've seen most of them,
but not this particular kind.
And then if I need to thin it,
I'll know by tasting and so on.
And then vanilla
or vanilla bean.
I put some vanilla
bean in because I
have all these vanilla beans.
And you know, one of
the really nice things
about vegan desserts too
is that you can taste away.
And you should taste,
because you don't
have to worry about salmonella.
There is no egg
situation here, right?
So you can just taste.
This isn't quite as
smooth as I'd like it.
So I'm going to put
a little bit of water
in and a little bit of
vanilla, and we're good to go.
Then I want to show
you how I measure.
And then you want cake?
We could start passing
the cakes around.
I don't usually do that
till I'm finished talking
because I lose everybody.
But I really am eager for
you to taste that cake.
Taste the cake because
that's where the proof is.
And is there anybody here
who can't have cashews?
Right, OK.
So we'll get the cakes served.
Ah-hah.
It's counter-intuitive.
The button goes down, not up.
There you go.
All right.
That looks much better.
You see?
So it's not as people say how
do you know when it's done?
When it's done.
Sometimes, baking the cake
should every risen, come away
from the sides, pulled
away from the sides,
and this wooden skewer inserted
in the center and pulled out
should be almost dry.
And if that's your only test,
the cake can be overdone.
So you start using
all of your senses.
I want to show you what I
do when the glaze is not
so perfect as Kathleen got the
glaze, which is pretty much all
the time for me.
For some reason, I
haven't mastered glaze.
But I do this.
And then I'm going to hit it
with a little gold luster dust.
And it looks like $1 million.
And your friends really think
that you worked extra long
on it.
What's that?
The gold luster dust?
Any cake shop-- any cake shop.
There you go.
So I do this pretty often.
And let's just see.
We've got so much
ganache that we
can have a little ganache on the
side so you can taste it also.
And here's the gold luster dust.
There we go.
Does anybody have any questions?
No?
That's a great question
because it depends.
When I'm doing just eight
ounces of chocolate,
or even 16, or
just in the mood--
it's like my relaxation-- then
on a very dry cutting board,
always with chocolate,
dry, dry, dry--
and I like a flex
board for chocolate
because it can go like that.
And I have either a
heavy knife like this
but from the corner of the
bar, and just keep going.
I happen to have a serrated
knife that isn't flexible
that I like.
If you're doing
quantity, what I'll do
is I'll chop 10 pounds
of chocolate at one time
and weigh it.
I really recommend those
little electronic scales
that cost pretty much nothing.
But they're really amazing
for weighing things.
Then I will chunk the chocolate
and put it in a dry food
processor, not too
much at a time,
and run it until
it's finely chopped.
Finely chopping your chocolate
really makes a difference.
Letting it relax, melt
slowly into the milk as well
really makes a difference.
If you're tempering
chocolate-- anybody here
interested in
tempering chocolate?
It's that shiny thing?
Well, nobody that I know,
not one single pastry chef I
know pretty much-- I
shouldn't say that.
Never say never.
People aren't really
tempering the old way,
which meant bringing
it up to temperature
and then smearing it on
a marble board and so on.
We seed temper.
So you guys can do
the math for me.
If you have x you
want to melt, 70%
of the chocolate
that you're melting,
and then hold out 25%
in a chunk or in chunks.
Those are the seeds.
And then bring it in
and let it stir again.
And that will take care
of keeping the chocolate
shiny for example.
But another workaround
is to just keep
things that are glazed
with that kind of chocolate
in the freezer really
tightly covered.
And that works.
So this, for
example, is the cake
that you're tasting
but sort of tarted up.
So it's a double layer cake.
It's a sachertorte with apricot
in the center and this cream
that you're having but
thicker-- by the way,
I love being in this Lebowski
room, because when I came in,
I'm like what?
There are vegan white
Russians in this book.
And yeah, in the
day, people used
to say-- I would hear
them behind me saying,
we're not sure about Costigan.
We don't really
think she's vegan.
She drinks wine.
She wears lipstick.
Nobody really does
things like that anymore.
But my son-in-law,
who is a great--
that film is the film
of all time, I think,
heard me talking about it.
And he said, oh my god.
How do you know about that?
And I'm like, really?
Give me a break.
You can make vegan
ice creams using
cashew cream base,
avocado base, or just
a plant milk base in the book.
And I don't know.
Do you know the
black bottom kind
of ice cream shell
that gets hard?
So there's a two
ingredient recipe
in here for that
ice cream sauce.
So I have ice creams.
I have creme brulee.
I have pies.
People say, how do
you get your ideas?
It's the things
that I like eating
and where I won't have to
use junkie, junkie stuff.
Because I won't use junk.
This is an opera cake
with a similar glaze
but made with a little bit
of agar to give it body.
And once you learn a
couple of the techniques--
so essentially that's
what I did today.
It was this.
But I just want to
show you the truffle.
I like to enroll truffles.
Just roll them.
This is the sesame truffle for
the person who liked tahini.
I just learned that
sesames are really high
up on the allergy alert scale.
And I wonder about all
these allergies now.
I certainly don't
make fun of it,
because I know that it's true.
But it wasn't true
back in the day,
and I'm clear that we just
broke the food system.
We're just doing things
to food that we shouldn't.
These are truffles made with
exactly what I did here,
but I infused the liquid with
spices and then strained it.
So you can do that-- curry,
or I really love ginger.
My new favorite
thing is turmeric.
Has that hit here?
Turmeric.
Fresh turmeric root.
So everything that I touch,
everything in my kitchen
is now orange because I haven't
figured out how to get it out.
So these are cashew
cream truffles,
but any truffle can be enrolled.
And this chocolate
was seed tempered.
But when I don't have time, I
put this, I said, in the book.
I said, well, you know,
sometimes they crack,
or I don't really even
feel like seed tempering.
I do the hybrid method.
So I dipped the truffles in
chocolate, let them get set up,
and then roll them a
little bit in a little bit
of dusting of cocoa powder.
And then you're good to go.
Nobody knows that
maybe it's not perfect.
The last thing I
want to show you--
and then I want to invite
everybody up to get some cake.
We've got berries
there and the cream.
And I'm going to cut this.
This is how I measure.
So if you go to my
YouTube channel,
I have a cookbook trailer in
English and in German now.
The person who dubbed my voice
in German sounds very stern.
And one of my
German-sounding friends
said I don't think that's
going to sell any books.
But anyway, that's
what happened.
I choose my battles.
I'm not I'm not
fighting over it.
So who bakes here?
Anybody bake?
Yay.
Great.
So some recipes say spoon
the flour into the cop,
and my recipes say
quite the opposite.
Did you just see me whisk?
So I aerate all of
my dry ingredients--
flour, sugar cocoa powder.
My book is in metric
as well as weights,
and I know metric is-- I
mean [INAUDIBLE] is cups.
I know metric is supposed
to be exact, but we found--
I had a bunch of
interns with scales--
and we found it wasn't.
How fine is the
sugar, and how long
has the flour been sitting?
So I whisk
everything, and then I
do what I call whisk,
dip, and sweep.
So I whisk, overfill, and with
a flat edge just go like this.
And then this goes.
I don't have a sifter-sifter,
but I absolutely recommend
sifting as part of the process.
So we're going to pretend that
this is all purpose flour,
whole wheat pastry flour.
Whole wheat pastry flour is
different from whole wheat
flour.
It's softer.
Cocoa powder.
And you need to know is
the cocoa powder alkalized,
or Dutch process, or natural?
The recipe should tell you.
They don't always.
One way to find out is if the
leavening is just baking soda,
you can be pretty sure that
it's natural cocoa powder.
And if it's baking soda,
baking powder, then it's
Dutch process or alkalized.
And then so everything's
in here now, right?
All of the dry ingredients?
And I whisk it, strain it.
I call it sifting into the bowl.
If you don't have whole
wheat pastry flour,
you can just add up the amount
of flour and use all AP.
And then the last step with all
these ingredients is to whisk.
And then all the liquid
ingredients in another bowl.
And I just don't
combine them until I
know that the oven rack is
in the right place, which
for a standard oven would be
the center, that the cake pan is
greased, oiled, and a piece
of parchment on the bottom.
And don't flip the
parchment over,
and don't use flour
unless the recipe
writer is telling you to do
it, but not with my recipes.
I find it doesn't work.
And then you're good to go,
and then put it in the oven.
So if you don't have time,
it's like the phone rang
or something, just don't
combine your batter.
I do recommend everybody has an
oven thermometer in their oven
because they vary
like crazy, right?
I had a brand new oven,
and I set it to 350.
And I looked at
it, and it was 425.
So my cake would have been
not very good, not very good
at all.
And here you go.
You did a gorgeous job.
Now, I would never serve
a piece of cake this big,
but I'm just
feeling like it now.
Yeah.
So nobody asked me
about replacing eggs.
So are you all just hip to that?
So I have never used
commercial egg replacer.
What I think is
that in the day--
because I started 22 years ago--
I don't know if there was any.
And I can always taste it.
And all it is, is a
mixture of starches.
So what function of the
egg are you replacing?
Liquid?
Very easy, right?
Binding?
Very easy.
Flavor?
No problem.
And so what I
figure is there were
a lot of accidentally
vegan recipes
that happened during the
war, that everybody's grandma
had a cake with baking powder,
baking soda, and vinegar.
And that's what leavens
your cake-- baking powder,
baking soda, and vinegar.
So my recipes say organic
sugar, organic flour,
aluminum free baking soda.
You don't have to use organic.
You don't have to use aluminum
free baking powder as long
as your baking powder is fresh.
I just figure,
for me personally,
once I've learned things I
can't get them out of my head.
So that's where I'm going.
But you do have
to measure right.
I just did an event at
a spa hotel last week.
And the pastry chef
wrote happy birthday
with the ganache, which is
a bit thicker on the plate.
Put it in the fridge.
You can do things like that
with a little squeeze bottle
and so on.
And it looks really beautiful.
You can also-- I like
a lot of berries.
Because this is California.
Boy, have you got fruit here.
Oh my goodness gracious.
You know, at home, I have
two kinds of avocados.
I went to the Hollywood
farmer's market,
and we had an avocado tasting.
I never saw such things.
Here we go.
Let's just really pile this up.
And here, sometimes
I will do a parfait.
You know, if you have left over
cake or just cut cake circles,
put them into a glass.
So you can serve
this on the side,
or you can just put it
over some of the berries.
I'm going to be around.
So while you're tasting,
if you have any questions,
just ask me questions.
I want to thank you
very, very much.
I hope you like the cakes.
I mean, that's the
proof really, isn't it?
No questions?
All right.
Well, if you think of
something, here I am.
Thank you.
Yum.
[APPLAUSE]